This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Dollar Shave Club.
Buying blades is the worst.
You have to go all the way to the store and
drop an A. Jack for a couple mediocre things?
Dollar Shave Club will SEND you blades, handles,
and other bathroom stuff; all for a few bucks
a month.
Shave time, shave money.
Join now and support the show by going to
dollarshaveclub.com/dnews
Cheers to beer!
Science has finally solved the riddle of all
that pesky foam at the top of your favorite
barley pop.
Howdy beer bellies, Trace here, thanks for
watching DNews!
Beer is an ancient cultured beverage made
by fermenting grains with active yeast, as
everyone knows.
There are innumerable quotes about beer out
there, and here's one more.
"Beer is real good."
You can take that one to the bank.
But there's something about beer that people
often deride, foamy head.
When a beer is poured, carbon dioxide or nitrogen
gasses dissolved in the liquid are released
forming those tiny bubbles.
Beer isn't the only liquid with dissolved
gasses in it though.
Sparkling water, soda, even cider has those
tiny bubbles, but none of them get head as
thick and static as beer.
Some beer foams last longer than the beverage
itself!
A new study from the Journal of the American
Society of Brewing Chemists digs into the
deep secrets of foam, exposing the truth.
Turns out the secret to beer foam is barley
lipid transfer protein No. 1! Yay!
I think.
A lipid is an umbrella term for a group of
organic fatty acids, mainly natural oils,
waxes and steroids.
Different raw grains contain different concentrations
of lipids, so different beers and brewing
methods will produce very different foams.
Soda, cider and sparkling water don't have
those lipid proteins, so they won't foam like
a beer.
I would like to point out, beer foam isn't,
in itself, a bad thing.
I know some bros in bro-town think foam is
totally like wasting the keg brah.
But in reality, some beers are foamier than
others.
According to a professor of food science and
technology at the New York State Agricultural
Experiment Station, the acidity of the beer,
number of molecular ions, ethanol levels,
viscocity, pH and so on and so forth all the
head on your cold ones.
According to Cornell biochemistry professor
Karl Siebert, there's a goldilocks zone for
beer.
High alcohol Belgian beers at 9-12 percent
and low alcohol beers like Bud Light // 3.2
percent, ladies // won't form foam at all.
Stuff THAT in your keg and drink it bros!
But a five percent beer, that's going to be
perfection.
When the beer is poured, the tiny bubbles
of gas will form, and stick to the LTP1 forming
a nice foamy head on the surface.
For beer aficionados, beer is like wine, so
many factors can go into the flavor, and head
is just one of them.
As my boy StrongBad once said, "A One that
is not cold, is scarcely a One at all."
Would you rather have a nice thick foam on
your cold beverage?
Tell us your thoughts in the comments below
and make sure you subscribe for more DNews.